i
cómo
las trabajadoras de la salud en américa
latina' pueden llegar a percibir hasta
un sueldo de media un 23 7 menor que sus
padres hombres por realizar exactamente
el mismo trabajo según se desprende de
un informe de la comisión económica para
américa latina y el caribe la cepal de
las naciones unidas'
este informe señala que los países más
dispares en los sueldos en la región son
panamá en torno a un 33% brasil que
supera el 27% chile que se acerca es el
mismo 27% y colombia donde la diferencia
en los sueldos entre hombres y mujeres
en el sector de la salud está en torno a
un 24% este es un sector además donde
hay una alta presencia laboral femenina
que constituye el 73 por ciento de la
plantilla laboral y que ha sufrido
también las consecuencias de la falta de
equipamiento y las jornadas extenuantes
según este informe de la cepal las
mujeres retrocedieron hasta una década
en temas de participación laboral como
consecuencia de la crisis económica
derivada de la pandemia
[Música]
el último informe de la comisión
económica para américa latina y el
caribe cepal coloca a panamá como el
país con la brecha salarial más grande
por razones de género situación que se
agudiza en el sector de la salud 32 por
ciento sería la diferencia de esa brecha
que favorece a los hombres sin embargo
uno consulta a enfermeras a médicos e
incluso a representantes del área
farmacéutica y cuentan que hay una
escala para cada cargo y que se respeta
independientemente del género la gran
diferencia radica fundamentalmente en
otro aspecto el informe muestra que 74
por ciento de los empleos son de mujeres
y sin embargo de acuerdo a las versiones
de las propias mujeres del sector
público de la salud los cargos
gerenciales en facturas direcciones que
tienen una mayor remuneración son
ocupadas aproximadamente el 90 por
ciento por hombres el nombramiento de
estas personas en estos puestos no
responde ni a logros ni a méritos
[Música]
la patera del cob y 19 ha incrementado
la brecha salarial que existe entre
hombres y mujeres en américa latina y el
caribe en el sector salud según la más
reciente informe publicado por la
comisión económica para américa latina y
el caribe cepal que revela que los
ingresos laborales de las mujeres que
trabajan en el ámbito de la salud son 23
puntos 7% inferiores a sus padres
profesionales hombres mientras que en
ecuador
esta cifra se ubica en el 20% por debajo
de los hombres la segregación laboral
también está subrepresentada en el campo
de la ciencia la tecnología e ingeniería
y matemáticas en este país la pandemia
profundizada desigualdad de género que
afecta a las mujeres con sobrecarga de
trabajo no remunerado pérdida de
ingresos y empleos los sectores del
turismo la enseñanza la salud y el
trabajo doméstico se evidencia un mayor
riesgo que afecta a las mujeres en
américa latina y el caribe a causa de
patrones culturales discriminatorios o
violentos o concertación de poderes
jerárquicos en el ámbito público entre
otros problemas estructurales 14
millones de mujeres de la región
salieron de sus empleos a causa del cob
y según el informe un obstáculo que
genera una menor autonomía y retos
económicos para su recuperación
[Música]